i love bread so much sorry
oprah it's ingrained in me in fact i
just
need it uh-huh that's another bread pun
20 20 has been such a tough year and
bread has been a huge
comfort and that's why i'm thrilled to
team up with panera bread
for this next segment we're going to
share some of our favorite bread related
stories of 2020
in a segment we're calling bread alert
here's our first story fresh out of the
oven
did any of you get into frog bread
no it's not bread made from
frogs it's bread that looks like a frog
these adorable amphibian-shaped loaves
were trending on social media back in
may
and as vice.com pointed out no two
loaves of frog bread are alike and
that's probably a big part of the appeal
frog bread lets us express ourselves
creatively at a time when we need a
therapeutic outlet more than ever
frog bread really rose to the occasion
yeah thank you frog bread
and someone in ottawa canada is giving
new
meaning to the term breadwinner
according to ctv news
one woman hosts a trivia game for her
co-workers
every friday morning and then delivers
her freshly
baked homemade bread to the winner she
told ctv
that she's baked hundreds of loaves over
the last few months
now this is the kind of bread news the
world needs right now
and i'm also wondering if this trivia
game is invite only or can anyone get in
on it
wait i'm getting a word that there's a
breaking bread alert
let's go to our boston bread
correspondent food influencer
brittany decapua
thanks drew i'm here at panera's
culinary kitchen and with me is the
world famous
chef's cloth now you're the new head
chef at panera what are your plans to
take the menu to the next level
we will base our cooking even more on
seasonality so we have
spring summer fall and winter and we
will bring in all the freshest
ingredients we can from the different
seasons and create something from that
we are actually launching three new
flatbread pizzas
and we're super proud of it so the first
one is chicken
chipotle bacon then we have this guy
here and this
is a margherita it's a classical pizza
we finish
with freshly cut basil like this so it
tastes like it's straight out of the
oven
in italy last one is a classical cheese
pizza
you're from sweden and you've worked all
around the world
why is your flat bread so special our
dough
is made from the best possible flour and
then we add some olive oil
and then we mix it and top it with all
our clean amazing ingredients and that's
why
it's going to taste amazing that's
really awesome thank you
now can we try a slice together
definitely
let's eat tasteless looks and smells so
good
cheers cheers
this is so delicious thank you so much
back to you drew
thanks brittany panera actually
sent me a delicious preview of their new
flatbread pizza
this one is the margarita i ate it right
away i loved it
so much thank you for that and everyone
at home for
breaking bread news with me thank you
panera it is a privilege to work with
you
i am so thrilled that you're getting
fresh quality ingredients to everyone